hey 42 here the rate of scientific
discovery is getting faster and faster
with major discoveries happening every
year rather than every century Mars
landings gravitational waves cancer
treatments vegan chili con carne we
really do seem to be able to achieve the
unthinkable but that's not to say we do
it all on our own since the dawn of
civilization animals have been more than
just our faithful companions and our
delicious lunch they have been a vital
part of our understanding of how the
world works and often an inspiration for
how to make it a better place so go give
Barkin Scorsese here next year cookie
let me Olli Cyrus upon the bed and
together we can learn about animals who
have helped advance of science dogs need
space
lots of it although the Soviets may have
taken this a little bit too far with the
legendary dog Laker when they fired her
out of the atmosphere and made her the
first animal to orbit the earth
mankind has had a long history of firing
animals into the sky since 1738 when the
Montgolfier brothers sent a sheep a duck
and a rooster up in a hot-air balloon
the Sheep was named Mono Co which means
climb to the sky they believe the Sheep
to have roughly similar physiology to a
human and the duck and the rooster work
control animals this is science after
all but also because they fought it was
funny to see how a sheep a duck and a
rooster get on in a hot-air balloon
together this set the standard and by
the 1940s the skies were filled of
balloons and Rockets being tested by
frogs fruit flies fish and monkeys among
many others it was like a Disney movie
directed by Michael Vick
lekha was sent into orbit on November
the 3rd 1957 to test how both the
g-force of the launch and microgravity
would affect a living organism
Paul acre just believed that someone had
thrown a stick really really far the
brave beast died within hours from
overheating but there was never any
intention to bring her home which many
of the scientists say they regretted
later on if you were ever embarrassingly
mugged by a sheep and had to pick one
out of a police lineup you
probably struggle to tell the difference
this may be why the Roslin Institute in
the University of Edinburgh decided to
use sheep as cloned subjects if it
didn't work they could have just grabbed
any other sheep and said look see that
just like twins but work it did and
Dolly the sheep was born on 5th July
1996 she was named dolly since the
original cell was taken from a mammary
gland which made the team think of Dolly
Parton the famously glandular singer
like an extreme episode of the Jeremy
Kyle show dolly had three different
motors one gave the egg one gave the DNA
and the final one did the whole
pregnancy thing honestly I think I was
her episode last week although not the
first cloned animal
Dolly was the first clone of an adult
animal proving that you could revert an
organism back to its embryonic state the
process is called somatic cell nuclear
transfer where you take out the nucleus
of a developing egg cell and put it in
the nucleus of a developed adult cell
like putting your Grandad's in a pair of
Converse and skinny jeans and seeing if
he fits in as a Skrillex concert thanks
to dolly we may be able to preserve
endangered species and even revive
extinct ones by the process she helped
to pioneer do you find your goldfish
suspicious always staring at you of
those googly eyes and gormless
expression well it may be a Soviet spy
we've used many different beasts for
spying over the centuries pigeons
carrying messages ducks duck can sniff
out weapons and cuts that are really
good at hacking well I assume that's why
they always sit on your keyboard looking
suspicious recently Hamas captured in a
kwatak spy near the coast of the Gaza
Strip it was a dolphin both Israeli and
Palestinian media said that double-o
dolphin was a quick recording devices
and even an arrow firing weapon it's
thought that he was there to take video
of the frogmen training facility
presumably so that they could plan an
attack using a ninja octopus and a
really angry seahorse
dolphin secret agents and that's a new
thing though we've been using them since
the 1960s for a variety of poll poises
to the purposes both the US and the
Soviets had dolphin teams to spot
underwater mines and they still do since
their echolocation is still far superior
to any tech we've been able to create so
far as far as killing goes there have
been no reported incidents but ex-navy
seal Brandon Webb taught in his memoir
about training dolphins to headbutt
enemy targets with a compressed needle
which could inject lethal bubbles of co2
into their blood
beware the killer spider thens the
Israelis have been accused of having a
whole zoo of animal agents from muster
mining the shark attacking Sharm
el-sheikh - a surveillance vulture
captured in Saudi Arabia I'm looking
forward to bacon born the swine sleeper
agent speaking of porky animals hum the
chimp was another great in the story of
space exploration ham was born in what
was then the French Cameroon's but was
shipped to the u.s. at a young age to
join the school for Space Chimps at the
Holloman Air Force Base in Alamogordo
New Mexico this was all part of Project
Mercury the NASA mission to put a human
into space on the last day of January
1961 ham was strapped into a nappy and
then into a rocket where he spent sixty
minutes being successfully launched up
to zero gravity and then coming back
down into his casual he helped NASA gain
valuable data about the life-support
system they would use soon after for
Alan Shepard the first American and
second human to enter space but how did
ham feel about all of this famous
primate expert - Jane Goodall was highly
critical of the mission and on reviewing
the footage said that she had never seen
a chimp look more terrified Sergio
canavero is a maverick surgeon who has
been working his way up the animal chain
with the dubious aim of performing a
full human head transplant
dr. vladimir demikhov led a lot of
advancement in the field of
transplanting performing a lot of
different operations in the 40s and 50s
and pioneering the use of
immunosuppressants so that the body
would accept new body parts and in 1959
he even transplanted a dog's head onto
new body neurosurgeon Robert Jay white
performed a successful monkey head
transplant in 1970 with the animal
surviving long enough to see smell and
hear the world around it it then decided
it didn't think much of the world around
it and proceeded to bite people
so it's undoubtedly possible for humans
but the ethical questions it raises a
pretty big how do you define a person am
I only me above the nipples above the
neck and what if the body I'm
transplanted onto has a one direction
tattoo death would probably be a better
option our final scientific assistance
is a Wii Bionic beast who like his
namesake
Oscar Pistorius bounces around on blades
Oscar lost both his back lights in a
nasty accident with a combine harvester
down on the channel island of Jersey
his owners rejected advice to have him
put down and soon they were
communicating with neuro orthopedic
surgeon no Fitzpatrick in the UK and
organizing for Oscar to have specially
engineered honeycomb shaped implants
that would be drilled directly into his
remaining ankle bones this technique was
designed to mimic how deer antlers grow
and the LAV skin to grow over the point
where the implant joins the body and so
to prevent infections the whole process
would probably cost around 50,000 but
most of that was covered by the
pioneering doctors rather than the
owners and the knowledge they gained has
now been used to help humans such as a
woman injured in the July 2005 London
bombings so rather than just putting
your hamster on a wheel or getting your
puppy to play fetch maybe try something
a little more challenging for a change
as your pet may have to key to a cure
for cancer or they could just teach you
a really useful shortcuts of Microsoft
Excel folks for the view subscribe for
more 42 you'll probably pass by anything
nothing more about it but this is the
smallest town in all of America with a
grand population of just one there are
hidden oil wells all over Los Angeles
these secret oil wells are hidden right
in plain sight somewhere next to schools
and shopping malls